and aaron nola will have to deal with
them tonight
a 3.64 era it's i i think an aranola
terms is high for him
yeah there's a little high for him and i
know that he's a little bit more of a
perfectionist
this is going to be a tough task these
guys can really swing the bats
and here's j.d martinez last night's
ultimate hero
runner on the move and a base hit so
verdugo touching second on his way into
third
fables puts on the stop sign and he
dives on back so the red sox have him on
at the corners with one away so first
and third for xander who's second in the
league and hitting it 344
chops that one to the first baseman
hoskins back to the bag as the run comes
in to score
and the red sox take a one-nothing lead
xander bogarts will pick up the rbi
chopping now raffy who's at 276 with 11
homers
goes the other way with this one deep
drive got you back to the wall
leaping can't get it off the top of the
fence
comes back into play run is in and all
the way down to second rafael devers he
just
missed a home run and the red sox lead
it two to nothing
it seems like a bad little breakup ball
back door and he can lead the other way
where is that thing
oh yeah yeah there's a chain-link fence
there there it is
right off the bottom of that team perez
one and two earned run average at 340.
yeah that leads all starters at 3.4 era
he's been good last four starts
the over shift on against mccutcheon
former nash league mvp
zipped in there and mccutchen will take
a seat
martine strikes out his first batter
tonight gets the lead off man
that won't be the last one bryce harper
at 294 with seven home runs
front door slider yes he struck him out
nice start for martin perez he bans
hartford two k's in the first
hunter retro leads it off top of the
second
and a strike three call beautiful pitch
second strikeout for nola
one out here in the second marwin
gonzalez the batter
swag and a miss he threw a dandy
curveball
three strikeouts in a row for nola
really excellent pitch he was burying
him inside with the fastball he throws
what appears to be another fastball to
gonzalez and he
snaps off and it's a nasty breaking ball
right underneath the swing
two outs here in the second and perez is
coming
[Music]
look at his teammates mr willis let's go
that is uh
that was interesting to say the least
here's a double herrera
he's been one of their hotter hitters in
nine game history
[Music]
what a play here from the knees bogus
gets him at first base
with santana stretching outstanding play
with the runner moving up
zander getting it done defensively
xander knows you know when you move to
that shift position you're on the
second base side you can make these kind
of plays and he goes into the dive
and he knows when he gets up he doesn't
have a long throw to make and for a
short stop that's a real
short throw to me thank goodness two
outs and now xander beauregards is
coming up
the rudder goes the pitch swung on him
missed he got him
and a lot more bite and finish on that
curveball big time
and where he was at the start no runs
one hit
and a man left by the red sox we're
going to the bottom of the third inning
it's boston two and the phil's nothing
want to know to mccutcheon he struck out
his first time up he lines that one out
toward right center field verdugo's on
the road he can't get it it's a one hop
off the scoreboard
mccutcheon going to second base and he's
there standing
a two out double his fourth double of
the year
so man in scoring position here and gene
segura coming up he grounded out the
short
his first time up and a high fly ball to
deep left center field martinez going
back
it is gone a two-run
home run for segora and we are tied up
at
two well he gets a hanging pitch right
here in the middle of the plate
and he absolutely crushes it and it
wasn't
no doubt
and i think he knew it as well that's
one of the longest home runs i could
remember him hitting
i don't mean that part of the ballpark
absolute towering drive because a little
cutter that stays in the middle of the
plate and he absolutely
spins on it i think he knew it was gone
433 feet first free pass
issued here's the national league leader
grinding at a double plays
he's grounded into 11. a good time for
that
3-2 pitch now to balm and hammered
and going right into a twin killing
double play
[Applause]
this is why they call it branch work
alina
and you get two out of it you get two
outs out of that oh
might have painted the might have
painted the chalk line there
there's danny santana rounded out 4-3
and flied to right
this is his red sox debut one two from
nola
swing that one rocketed down the line
hit it for the corner and she is gone
say hello to danny santana who launches
one out of the ballpark and puts the red
sox
back in front welcome mr santana a
little hook
he left the yard a solo shot here in the
fifth inning and the red sox lead at 3-2
curveball in his eyes yeah it's like he
was just waiting for a breaking ball
right there he looked so
good swaying at that pitch red sox
trying to build something
and verdugo is his second when martinez
at first for xander bogart
swinging a line drive left field gets
down for a base hit verdugo hits third
here he comes mccutcheon's throw cut off
they got jd in a rundown but they
dropped the ball segura dropped the ball
jd to third and he's coming home now as
the ball
is dead in shallow center field two runs
score
and over to third goes bogarts and the
red sox lead at 5-2
what a mess what a mess is got a pitch
to hit either rope
but he rot rifles at the left field and
then all the fun begins
the guru can't handle it and it sits
there forever
look at both of them he's got to jump a
little piece over there
look at this it's a beautiful thing look
at this hurdle yes
vazquez looking to reach for the first
time high fly ball he hit it deep left
field backing up mccutchen at the wall
leaping up can't get it it's off the
fence
scooped up by herrera and
easily into second base vazquez and a
couple of red sox have
just missed home runs tonight yeah the
top of the fence yeah i mean
and both look like they were going to be
out of the ballpark here's renfro red
sox really trying to stretch this lead
out here
here's the pitch to renfro that's hard
on the ground in the left field to base
it
vasquez comes to third he's waved home
mccutchen bobbles it
because of that renfro heads for second
he slides in safely it's an rbi
single for renfro and it's 6-2 red sox
phillies don't have to get it all back
at once but they need to get after it
here is alec baum and segura goes to
third
looper out to left field and it's going
to drop in for base hit martinez can't
get it it's an rbi segura will score
and alec bowm has two hits tonight it's
a 6-3 ball game
and two gone and the red sox seventh pk
stay in put
it'll be up to raffy looking for his
second rbi tonight
he's gonna turn on that one he pokes it
down the line and that is gone
rafael devers with a two-run homer
and the red sox open up an 8-3 lead i
got your
up right here and he just lost it
another high
change up in his eyes and just a flick
of the wrist
that's all that was a flick of the wrist
and the base is full for vasquez
he struck out fly there right double off
the top of the wall and left center and
fly to center
high fly twisting deep to the corner and
harper can't get it that takes a bounce
one run in two runs in three runs in
martinez bogart's endeavors all score
vasquez cleans them off
and the red sox lead it 11-3 very very
good night for the sox again
they are one out away from going to 10
over
500 for the first time here in 2021
swinging a miss
at a high fast ball fitting this game
ends on a strikeout
30 strikeouts in the game but the red
sox win it
11-3 their third straight victory
so they're guaranteed of keeping their
lead in the american league east boston
11
philadelphia 3.